what's going on guys this is rob and
kind of continuing our preparation for
thor 4 which isn't going to come out for
a long long time
i don't know why we're doing these
videos in preparation for thor 4. uh
we're explaining gore the god butcher
now here's the caveat to this
there are two things to know one gore
the god butcher does not have a lengthy
history
in marvel comics and two we covered the
entirety of the gore the god butcher run
now
gore's story in marvel is one part or
really the beginning part of a much
larger run called the jason aaron run on
thor those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with comics and i know a lot
of you guys who are watching this are
probably familiar
bear with me here for a second those
guys who are unfamiliar usually have
entire runs of characters or teams for a
particular writer so when jason aaron
took over
thor he basically built a little bit on
what had already been done but by and
large
it's a great starting point right thor
god of thunder is where you're
introduced to gore
and then just read forward from there i
consider jason aaron's thor run to be
the single greatest thor run of all time
and so i would highly suggest that you
read the whole thing if you decide to go
with it but because gore does not have a
lengthy history this video is not going
to be
overly long so for gore himself his
first appearance came with thor god of
thunder number two
in 2012 and the way this worked is that
gore was given to us as
what is basically part of a
superstitious tribe that in reality he
and his people lived on a world that was
never really given to us by name but the
idea was they would pray to their gods
on a daily basis under the idea
that the very harsh world that they
lived on would grant them you know some
kind of a lush jungle
or resources or whatever it is that they
needed to survive one day to the next
and that was really all as people could
ever really hope for just the ability to
survive
from one day to the next now for the
rest of his tribe if there was any doubt
the gods existed
they never voiced it right for the most
part they seemed to have this almost
zealot belief
that gods were definitively real and
they would continue to pray for them and
that if they didn't get any kind of
nourishment right if it didn't rain
or they didn't come across a jungle or
something like that it's because well
the gods are making us stronger so that
we can survive for another day and
using whatever internal justification
made sense so they could maintain their
own belief system
gore was not that way at least he was
initially but not
later because of the harsh environment
in which they lived there was it was not
uncommon to lose
family members and in gore's particular
instance he basically lost his wife and
his kids right now it didn't happen all
at once
it happened over time a lot of them died
due to starvation or due to thirst his
wife died in an earthquake his oldest
son died of starvation and so by the
time his oldest son agar had died he was
just
basically fed up and he ultimately
cursed the gods in front of his tribe
his
whole philosophy was if the gods were
real then we wouldn't be living in this
kind of circumstance
and so his philosophy was that the gods
inherently are evil more or less
if gods are real but these are the
circumstance they're living in and the
gods can hear their prayers then the
gods don't care
and if that's not the case then the gods
aren't real but regardless of the
situation
as far as he was concerned there are no
gods right there's nobody out there
looking out for us but because
of the religious fundamentalist nature
of his tribe they exiled him now
while he was exiled and kind of out
doing his own thing he ultimately came
across
a couple of different gods who had
basically died in a fight now one thing
i want to clarify here when the story
was originally written in 2012
neither one of these gods were given
names they had simply just come crashing
out of the sky
and landed on the ground and they were
both basically dead after having fought
each other now this
changed in donny kate's run on venom and
that's something else to understand if a
lot of you guys who are new a writer
might introduce a thing and then do
nothing with it right like just kind of
some small little throwaway thing and
then another writer might look at that
and say i can use that in this
instance the god that was kind of clad
in black basically turned out to be null
as it was established by donnie cates
much later on now those guys who don't
know who knoll is nola is a really
really fascinating character he's
basically the being that's responsible
for the creation of the living abyss
which is where like the venom symbiote
the carnage symbiote all those things
kind of originate from technically
carnage is the offspring of venom but
they're all more or less part of the
same race a lot of that's built on some
of the work with regards to planet of
the symbiotes that was done by brian
michael bendis during his guardians of
the galaxy run
so it was one of those things where it's
just kind of been built on over the
years in different forms or fashions
coming to the realization that gods were
real
ultimately gore ended up shunning the
gods because he kind of came to this
realization
that his argument that the gods were
real but they didn't care about anybody
was true
and so ultimately he became vengeful and
so in doing this he essentially sees
what was called the all-black necro
sword essentially not really a source
of knoll's power but a portion of
knoll's power it basically granted him
powers and then boosted the powers that
it gave him and then he kind of went
forward across the universe
killing virtually every god he could
find now the reality is we weren't
really given
an actual time frame when that happened
with
gore all we knew was that he had kind of
gone on this quest for seemingly
thousands of years right so it seemed to
have happened thousands of years before
the modern day
on earth but during the 9th century he
showed up on earth as part of his
campaign to kill gods
and then killed a handful of gods from
the united or at least what would become
the united states from essentially north
america
and then in turn that body washed up on
iceland thor became aware of what was
happening
and then went to go find out what had
taken place only to find that all these
gods had basically been killed by gore
the god butcher now something that i
want to point out here is that during
this time there had never really been
this sort of exploration of gods in
marvel comics
it never really been done on this scale
before by and large when it came to gods
in marvel you were limited to whatever
beings you had seen up to that point
right so the sky
fathers is a really good example the sky
fathers was basically a pantheon
of the kind of religious heads or the
deities that are worshiped by multiple
citizens or multiple people from across
the world right so like zeus and odin
and vishnu and people like that
on other worlds we never really knew
what their gods looked like we had some
limited exposure
shara and ki3 from the shia empire for
example but we didn't really have a
whole lot of
of you know experience there and so
jason aaron's work on expanding the
godly mythos and basically saying there
are
entire pantheon of gods that belong to
entire worlds that exist across the
entirety of the universe and all these
different you know galaxies
it's huge it's wildly complex and so it
was kind of a big deal in terms of this
expansion but with thor becoming aware
of what gore had done
that thor in turn faced off with gore
seemingly for the very first time and
was absolutely
crushed right was was absolutely just
destroyed by this guy
to the point that thor was almost killed
now a couple things to know the way that
jason aaron did this he played it fast
and loose with what gore was really
capable of
because at this point in time thor had
not quite gained the ability to wield
his hammer mjolnir he was still
considered to be unworthy so all he had
was his battle axe and so it was kind of
left at least this little bit of a story
was left on the possibility that if thor
and gore ever face off against each
other in the future that thor would
ultimately win now the other part of
that is it was kind of left off with
thor having
you know having cut off the arm of gore
and then believing he had killed him but
as the reader
it was kind of left to us you know
really jason aaron telling us like gore
is obviously not dead right
it was kind of how it was stated so over
the course of the remainder of the run
what you ended up seeing was gore
returning yet again thousands of years
later after having killed even more gods
and imbued himself with even more power
and then ultimately using the living
abyss to create a kind of army for
himself and then in turn
fought thor again this time when thor
had mjolnir and yet again
gore won and so it's one of these things
where gore was just kind of established
as being just this massive heavy hitter
a lot of it being due to the fact that
over the time between
thor basically facing off against them
the first time and thor facing off
against him the second time
that despite having mjolnir gore had
just become more and more powerful
and so ultimately the way this played
out is i saw jason aaron introducing
what was in effect
all father thor now part of this was due
to the actions of gore and the other
part of it was actually due to the
actions of loki so the way this had
played out as far as loki went with
regards to the old journey and it were
really the more recent journey into
mystery stories is that you ended up
finding out that in this far-flung
future
loki had essentially killed everybody on
earth now while the asgardians
themselves were fine
this more or less coincided with gore
the god butcher in this far-flung future
basically taking his army of you know
living abyss
minions more or less and descending on
to asgard and so those asgardians who
were not killed
were captured and forced into the
service of of gore whose intention we'll
talk about here in a second
and basically what it meant was that all
father thor was basically the only
asgardian that was left he was
ultimately captured and then forced into
the subservience of gore but really more
just kind of taunted with the fact that
all the asgardians had been killed by
gore and gore's own kind of grim
satisfaction in knowing that he had
essentially won now in terms of what
gore's motivation
was because of the fact that going
across the universe and killing
virtually every god he could find was a
lengthy process
he had the age to do it the problem with
this is that one of the things that had
happened over the course of the thor god
of thunder story is that there were god
refugees which is to say those
individuals who had heard what gore was
doing
and then basically went into hiding and
this ultimately meant that gore
could not satisfy his ultimate goal to
kill every single god across the
universe throughout all space and time
and so what he ended up doing was
basically working to construct something
called the god bomb and the whole idea
behind this is he would detonate it in
the time stream and the explosion would
emanate outward from whatever point in
time it detonated
and essentially kill every god across
the entirety of the universe's history
regardless of where they were hiding
and so what this did is it ultimately
led to thor from the past
teaming up with thor from the present
along with thor from the future right so
three generations of thor
all facing off against gore and the
battle was absolutely
insane right it's one of the craziest
things you're ever gonna see there was
actually an instance in this story where
i believe it was present-day thor
had wielded two mjolnirs right one from
his present-day self and one from his
future self
along with the all-black necro sword
right it was absurd how powerful
he was but even then he didn't seem to
have the power
to destroy gore now this is where jason
aaron's thor run took a really really
interesting direction because not to
sound
too corny here but the story largely
began to shift and and really if i'm
being honest had focused a lot already
on the power of prayer in the sense that
when it comes to those different gods
that exist out there thor people like
that
that while thor is imbued with what is
in effect the thor force right the
source of his energy which is something
akin to the odin force but not quite on
the same level depending on who you're
reading about right if you go back and
you read
uh thor ragnarok for example thor's
version of the thor force was
essentially equal to the power of the
odin force or if you look at all father
thor
his power was equal to the odin force
but if you look at thor in his younger
years i guess it hadn't quite grown to
that level honestly
marvel's exceedingly murky about it but
despite all of that
a portion of thor's power actually comes
from those who believe
in him right who actually pray to him
and that's one of the things that jason
aaron had really hit on that hadn't
quite been
explored before you assumed that half of
his power came from his father odin and
the other half came from his mother
gaia who is basically the sentience of
earth although recently i believe
marvel's changed that and actually said
that his
biological mom is really the phoenix
force which is kind of a weird
a weird change of things but regardless
the important thing here is that the
various gods that exist
across the universe only really have the
power they have
because people believe in them and
because people worship them the
antithesis to this
is that if people stop believing in gods
and stop worshipping gods then in turn
gods will lose their power and that was
really where the crux of of gore the god
butcher's
role came into play in the sense that
his desire was not to kill innocent
believers right that was never really
his goal his vengeance was against the
gods now he did believe in collateral
damage right so if some believers run up
on him trying to kill him because he's
trying to kill one of their gods well
then you know sorry about your luck
right but at the end of the day he
wouldn't go out of his way and
annihilate an entire planet of innocent
people for the sheer fun of it right he
wasn't like thanos in that way and so
what had happened was a kind of
manifestation of gore's son agar had
appeared
and then basically shunned his father
and said you have become everything that
you hate
and then in turn started praying to thor
this alongside all the other gods that
it had basically survived from across
all time in space
praying to thor basically boosted his
power and it ultimately led to thor
killing gore but following that it was
kind of a funny thing gore you talk to
anybody who read
jason aaron's god of thunder and they'll
tell you gore was definitively one of
the greatest comic book villains ever
created
literally across the board right just in
terms of interest his intrigue
why he did what he did his motivations
how he was written he was just one of
the most compelling villains that marvel
had ever created and people wanted to
see him come back
right they wanted to see him return and
so ultimately he did
the biggest problem that you had with
this and i don't know if i'd necessarily
call it a problem honestly the people
who complained about it it was kind of
smatterings across the internet wasn't
really a great big huge
beef with it but the entirety of gore's
return and the motivation and really
what he did
seemed to kind of betray the motivation
of his character initially right in the
sense that al gore wanted to do was kill
gods with gore's return
a couple things had happened since then
the first was that with loki having
eradicated all life on earth
that that life had basically been in the
process of returning
due to the power of all father thor it
was always all the way to the point
where you actually had
citizens on earth right people on earth
who were living their lives nowhere near
advanced as
modern society it was pretty advanced
right so let's say humanity
20 000 years ago but that's basically
what you saw living in the world people
who kind of believed in thor and all
that kind of good stuff
the other part of this is that loki in
this far-flung future had managed to get
his hands on the all-black necro sword
and the goal was to use it to basically
kill all father thor
the biggest issue with this is that
gore's consciousness had existed within
the sword
and so when loki had seized it he had
also resurrected war
gorg basically impaled loki seemingly
killing him and then in turn went to go
fight all father thor so
unlike the original gore the god butcher
story you didn't see thor's from three
different eras facing off against score
instead
it was just all father thor in the
future but where things shifted up
is that the fight moved away from being
what was
really more of like a glorified bare
knuckle battle and in turn
it turned into like this massive
conflict now a lot of this was due to
the fact that all father thor had
possessed such an immense level of power
at that point in time literally the
ability to essentially create life and
then at the same time
gore had to become something equally as
powerful which he'd essentially become
now a lot of that seemed to be
predicated on what was going on with
regards to noel the symbiote god and
donnie case's venom the fact that null
was so
incredibly powerful that anybody who
wielded the all-black necro sword had to
essentially be equally powerful
otherwise the inconsistency would be too
big to ignore and so that basically led
to
gore eventually kind of facing off
against thor and actually laying waste
to entire star systems and then it
actually got to a point where gore
himself had imbued himself with the
power of the all-black necro sword in
his entirety and then
quite literally recreated all of
existence to the point that he was a
full-on universe and it actually
almost managed to kill all father thor
now the funny thing about this is that
this battle between
all father thor and gore was basically
the very tail end of jason aaron's run
it was the last story arc he wrote
before he put down the pen and just kind
of said okay i'm done writing
thor now the result of this is that all
father thor defeating gore
actually came at the power of the hands
of the god tempest now the god tempest
was
jason aaron's way of explaining why it
is
that thor had lost the ability to wield
his hammer the reality is that that had
taken place
during a story called original sin and
you basically had nick fury who had
whispered something to thor and then we
never really we didn't find out what it
was for
years right but thor essentially became
unworthy the reality and as far as i
understand it
uh jason aaron had actually wanted to
write that but because marvel was going
into secret wars in 2015
there certainly wasn't any time for it
right either that or jason aaron was
just playing the long game
depending on who you talked to myself
included jason aaron waited too long
and so the interest and the intrigue had
built up to such a point
that no answer he gave would be a good
answer the reality was that nick fury
had basically told thor
gore was right right the gods weren't
worthy but the important thing about
this is that an origin
for the hammer of mjolnir in terms of it
determining who's worthy and who's not
had kind of been expanded on by jason
aaron in so far that it wasn't simply an
enchantment that was placed on the
hammer by odin that instead the god
tempest was really like this cosmic
storm
that had existed since the very
beginning of all things and that as time
progressed the storm would grow in scale
now
seemingly it was one of those things
where the storm grew in direct
proportion to the size of the universe
right so the more time that passes the
bigger the universe gets until it
reaches
its heat death and starts to crunch back
down and then eventually die
uh and so until that point the storm
would just continue to grow and grow and
grow
eventually odin harnessed the power of
the storm and then confined it inside of
mjolnir and so more or less the hammer
decides who's worthy
not necessarily the enchantment of odin
the enchantment seems to be a compliment
to it but at the end of the day the
decision
ultimately rests with with the hammer
itself in terms of the god tempest
operating inside the hammer and having
really a mind of its own and so that was
kind of the explanation that was kind of
book-ended into why it is
that thor lost the ability to wield his
hammer and then the title passed on to
uh to jane foster who became the new
thor
and then thor just kind of went back to
being odin's son which seemed to piss
off a lot of people honestly i thought
their anger was kind of silly but the
important thing here
is that the god tempest was literally
cosmic power that was virtually
just unbridled energy and so during this
final battle with gore what had happened
was that uh all father thor had
essentially
unleashed the god tempest which was a
basically the power of a universe
and so it ultimately overwhelmed gore
and then gore was
finally dead right gore was completely
and totally dead and obliterated now
whether or not gore will come back we
don't fully know in reality gore seems
to be the baby of jason aaron right that
gore is one of these characters where he
was created and killed by jason aaron
somebody may bring him back at a future
point in time honestly
i wouldn't really expect it to uh gore's
interesting enough but the reality is if
anybody came back and and resurrected
gore
i don't think fan reception would be as
high to that as it was
when gore originally appeared because
it's one thing one of these things i
mean
i highly suggest you guys watch the
video that i did the the appearance of
gore
in marvel was just amazing right it was
like the the original story arc right
like thor god of thunder like the whole
god butcher story was just
fantastic that whole run was it was the
stuff of legend right it's one of the
greatest thor
comic book stories ever told ever right
it's just it's it's phenomenal the way
that it was handled and so because it
was done so well as comic book fans
we tend to look on it with nostalgic
glasses and so any other depiction of
gore that we'll see
especially when you see him in the mcu
is gonna be compared to that comic book
story arc and people will decide whether
or not they like it
based on comparing it to that comic book
story arc right so it's one of these
little interesting things that kind of
goes on with fandoms right i mean i'm
guilty of this
of this travesty i wish i wasn't you
know i wish i wasn't guilty of that you
know it's one of the things that i don't
like about myself
being a comic book fan but it's kind of
hard to separate myself from that after
so long so with that being said guys
this is basically the history or the
comic book explanation of gore again
not a whole lot to go on here right this
guy had only been around for a couple of
years had appeared in probably about 20
or 30 comic book issues if that
and then was ultimately removed from the
landscape so with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching
and i will catch you all later peace